[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là vous
tellement possible la boue à
à quillan thomas
regarde l'amour
à qui le veut
frémont john adapté je sais même pas
pourquoi ils m'ont déguisé franchement
j'aurais pu rester normal ccvla l'aller
chabert people7 beaucoup d'ailleurs à
l'époque pourquoi on s'est mis comme ça
car ce soir nous allons accueillir garou
garantie serait notre invité garou tina
découvert bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
comment l'amour
tous les chroniqueurs sont en
personnages de comédie musicale et on va
cuire pour commencer la chanson qui t'a
fait connaître bien entendu quasimodo
frollo esmeralda à votre avis qui fait
quasimodo en basset bernès
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
seul
sur la vie de ma mère c'est son meilleur
jeu vraiment très moyen mais là j'ai
presque envie de tout envoyer faire du
stop ainsi faire rouler ce mois rien dit
c'est deux doigts sous les allez on va
passer maintenant à j'adore mozart
l'opéra rock
[Musique]
chaud
elle est née au maroc le pays du soleil
bien sûr
alors forcément valérie bénaïm est
aujourd'hui le roi soleil
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
tirez pas du tout le roi soit on débraye
touche aouate
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voici sandy et dany de crise c'est parti
[Musique]
jean-mi et francesca qui nous font
royaux et juliette sais pas
c'est la plus
oh
[Applaudissements]
et loin
oh
c'est
[Musique]
battant démentir et marilyn manson est
féroce
merci qui doit alors voilà on va faire
tout de suite un jeu qui doit retourner
au bois de boulogne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]